furthermore we wouldn't expect those
bindings to remain true across every
single invocation of this function if
all of this seems completely obvious to
you then you're in a great position for
understanding the parameter this because
in JavaScript the keyword this behaves
like a parameter in most of the
important ways the intuitions that
you've built up around how to pass
values into a function and how they'll
get bound to the arguments being passed
in a call time all those same intuitions
will hold true for the parameter this so
let's keep track of the output that
we're expecting to see by putting it in
a code comment here to the right of the
line that created we're ready to
investigate what would happen if our
function referred to the parameter this
inside the function body if we pass this
as an additional input parameter at the
beginning of the logging function call
in this case what should we expect to be
logged and bound to the parameter this
while the FN function is running go
ahead and write out your answer